[Music]
tyrese shared a heartbreaking update
about his mother priscilla murray amid
her ongoing health battles
on sunday the actor revealed she's
currently in a coma following her
diagnosis for covid19 and pneumonia
now tyrese is asking for prayers on
social media
and behind this door
is my mom right there
i'm sitting in a hallway
because they told me i can only be in
there with her while she has coveted
for 30 minutes at a time right now i'm
in icu
and
i can ask y'all to pray for my mom
on wednesday he shared this photo of the
hallway outside his mother's hospital
room
tyrese explained the difficult news he's
received about her health writing the
doctor sat in this chair and just broke
my heart by telling me there's pretty
much nothing else that can be done to
turn things around
on thursday tyree shared this photo of
him holding murray's hand simply writing
keep fighting mother please mother we
need you
all i want is for her to continue to
inhale
and exhale
that's all i want in another recent post
he shared a picture of himself praying
for his mother while on set
also on thursday tyrese posted this clip
from the oprah winfrey show when murray
received a special mother's day tribute
tyrese is here and he brought along the
rest of the family
he wrote in the caption in part quote
keep fighting god i want to say thank
you for every breath she takes
in the archival talk show clip tyrese
surprised his mother with a new house
to come all the way from watts to out
here
night and day this represents mother you
don't have to cry no more you've always
been there for me through thick and thin
god bless you
you